une fois de plus le groupe gbh va encore
prendre de plus en plus de parts de
marché il va passer de 16 millions à 30
millions d'euros gens vous avez plus qu
un seul acteur c'est l'acteur qui fait
les prix et ça n'est pas l'acheteur
qu'il fait des pins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors amis réunionnais amis réunionnais
bonjour cette vidéo s'adresse aux
membres de la commission départementale
d'aménagement commercial la fameuse cdac
qui se réunit très prochainement pour
examiner l'augmentation de surface
demandée par le groupe gbh groupe
bernard ioc pour augmenter le magasin
monsieur bricolage qui aujourd'hui fait
3000 mètres carrés le passé à 6000
mètres carrés cette opération c'est un
enjeu important
pourquoi parce que une fois de plus le
groupe gbh va encore prendre de plus en
plus de parts de marché sans pour autant
amener un service attendu ou souhaités
par les réunionnais je m'explique
aujourd'hui le groupe gbh à travers
monsieur bricolage locale fait à peu
près 16 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires à l'issue de cette opération
il va passer de 16 millions à 30
millions d'euros c'est pendant qu'il dit
c'est eux qui le disent dans les
documents qu'ils ont transmis à la
commission mais dans le même temps il
nous montre aussi l'affaiblissement de
la concurrence c'est-à-dire qu'ils
expliquent clairement que l'argent
qu'ils vont faire qui vont fabriquer
parce qu'ils seront en augmentation de
surface se fera au détriment des
concurrents locaux et ça ça nous
inquiète énormément pourquoi parce que
cet affaiblissement de concurrence
conduit progressivement à augmenter la
situation d'oligopole voire d'un
monopole du groupe gbh à la réunion je
me rappelle quand même que le groupe gbh
est extrêmement puissant la réunion il
est en situation position dominante on a
vu par exemple dans le cadre du rachat
de casino la fameuse affaire 20 des
biens contre laquelle nous chez air et
d'hommes nous avions lutté on avait dit
attention au danger que s'est il passé
fondamentalement
l'autorité de la concurrence à paris a
dit allez bien fait mais vous êtes dans
l'obligation de revendre des magasins
ils ont revendu des magasins gb h mais
les auront vendues à une enseigne que
vous connaissez tous kerron markets et
bien aujourd'hui rue marquette se porte
pas bien perte de chiffre d'affaires
perte de marge dont un danger très
important pour une market pour leur
survie non on voit bien que quand gvh
s'installe quelque part
non seulement il prend des parts de
marché mais il affaiblit
considérablement la concurrence et
qu'est ce qui se passe là de manière
naturelle c'est que les clients
reviennent chez eux pourquoi parce
qu'ils les enserre parce que ils ont une
politique de prix qui va être
extrêmement agressive pour éliminer le
concurrent piquant de le conclure et
éliminer après les prix remonter là
c'est la fête à saint pol si j'ose dire
donc évidemment il ne faut pas laisser
cette opération faire je m'en remet
encore à l'excellence de la pensée de
nos amis qui aujourd'hui vont avoir
cette lourde responsabilité au sein de
la commission de la cdac de prendre ses
décisions s'il vous plaît ne revenez pas
plus âgés mais alors pourquoi également
gbh dans le monde aujourd'hui du
bricolage à la réunion c'est plus de 40%
de parts de marché déjà quasiment 45% du
marché c'est considérable dont faut-il
encore aux mêmes acteurs lui donner
encore plus il faut de la concurrence
donc s'il vous plaît ne laissez pas
passer cette opération là ne croyez pas
évidemment le bouc gbh nous explique
qu'il est tout malheureux parce que mary
concurrents qui sont méchants avec lui
enfin soyons sérieux ce groupe est un
groupe qui est extrêmement puissant
c'est un groupe qui ne recule devant
rien pour augmenter ses profits
aujourd'hui il veut le faire encore plus
de profits avec une volonté très claire
c'est d'éliminer le plus possible la
concurrence ce qui leur permettra à
terme de faire ce qu'ils veulent on prie
encore une fois nous avons là
l'expérience du rachat d'un des biens
nous ce que nous disons aujourd'hui chez
les hommes c'est ceci nous disons que il
faut faire une autorité de la
concurrence qu'ils soient souveraine
dans chacun des territoires dont
évidemment à la réunion que cette
autorité de la concurrence puisse de
manière sectorielle aller voir un peu ce
qui se passe pas de partout où il ya des
positions dominantes qu'on ait déterminé
un peu qui fait quoi comment ça se passe
en termes prix et pour ça il faut donner
une puissance à cette autorité de la
concurrence locale en lui donnant ce
qu'on appelle un pouvoir d'injonction
structurelles salle une vraie capacité à
dire écoutez là vous êtes trop puissant
donc nous allons lui demander de
revendre des magasins vous êtes en
position ultra dominante dans tout
secteur l'automobile par exemple les
camions par exemple que j'en passe et
des meilleurs donc il faut contenir ce
groupe qui n'en finit plus d'une
expansion qui est une expansion qui va
finir par coûter très cher aux
réunionnaises et aux réunionnais parce
que quand vous avez plus qu un seul
acteur c'est l'acteur qui fait les prix
et ça n'est pas l'acheteur il fait des
prix merci beaucoup nous reviendrons là
dessus on va suivre ce dossier
évidemment et nous n'excluons pas une
action juridique pour entraver ce cette
prise encore de guerre que veut faire
aujourd'hui le groupe gbh en s'octroyant
encore et toujours plus de parts de
marché là où il en a déjà beaucoup à
bientôt amis réunionnaise amis
réunionnais nous suivons ce dossier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]